what's up it's christy theaters aka
chrissy beacon egg and cheese i'm doing
the beacon theater saturday february
fifth day of get tickets
chrisdcomedy.com from now on i'm only
answering to kevin beacon salt lake city
november fifth and sixth we've just
added salt lake city those tickets are
almost sold out and then november 21st
in boston
uh laugh boston is sold out so november
21st at the wilbur theater we got two
shows go get tickets christy comedy.com
and then we have phoenix and west palm
beach uh so it's been a lot of fun
christy comedy.com thanks for all the
people coming out go get tiki wikis all
right i finally got some dates for you
guys i will be at the dania improv in
fort lauderdale on november 12th 13th
and 14th i will be at the west palm
beach improv december 4th and 5th i will
be in boston in the medford area at the
chevalier theater on december 10th and
how about this first time playing
atlantic city solo i'm at the borgata
saturday december 11th come on down for
that
uh all tickets at
savilecanocomedy.com right now
and more dates to be announced soon i
have not been out i'm finally coming out
at the covent you better be
from your feelings there don't be afraid
don't be ashamed don't hesitate to say
hey babe hey babe hey babe hey babe hey
baby you know i'm bad hey babe you know
it
and the whole world has to answer right
now just to tell you once again hey babe
dude do you did we never do that one i
don't think we've ever done that one i
felt like hey babe do you know what the
first lyric is to the song bad by
michael jackson
uh your word the word is out
better get out your mouth want me to
tell you yeah your butt is mine
no it's not go go go go scroll up
look
your butt is mine are you serious the
lyrics are your butt is mine telling us
in broad daylight it says in broad
daylight
it says your butt is mine gonna take you
right just show your face in broad
daylight oh my god i'm telling you i
feel gonna hurt your mind don't shoot to
kill come on come on lay it on me all
right so i mean literally michael
jackson in broad daylight was saying
your butt's mine your butt is mine
and but i mean look we saw the video we
know it was like a gang it was like a
gang fight in a parking garage yes right
it was so so i get your ass is mine
but when you say butt it's interesting
it sounds like a little different i know
it's different like monica and brandy
your butt is mine you need to give it up
that's not a bad boy i know i know but
i'm saying your butt is mine
i like michael jackson's look he's got
the blazer with the hoodie he's got like
a like a very cleaned up homeless guy
like is that wesley snipes that was yeah
he's the gang leader in bed was this
before he was famous
i don't i think i no i think he was i
don't know
i thought he was famous already yeah
maybe he wasn't
no because wesley snipes was famous in
the 80s correct from a lot of from
certain angles and she knows this i've
people have said this before but jasmine
my girlfriend looks like michael jackson
[Music]
in the video no no no no no no like the
legitimate mother of my children looks
like michael jackson well when his hair
was long like that maybe she puts like
curly stuff like yeah is that what you
mean michael jackson looks like a puerto
rican transgender person when he was
when he was a young black male yeah
that's what it is that's freaking funny
do you pimp is michael jackson big in
the in the younger guys in their 20s
community no i just think of them from
comedy bits and having an amusement park
for children so you think of more of
michael jackson as the pedophile yeah uh
in my mind
but but but alleged
alleged good call very very true a
legend alleged
look he paved the way for the weekend
and everyone but at the same time the
weekend doesn't have an amusement park
for children we not that we know of yet
ah see
michael jackson
in michael jackson's early 30s nobody
knew about nothing but the weekend
didn't name himself like everyone's
favorite thing so yeah
who knows what he's trying to attract
it's true no
so many buckles on that outfit too many
buckles almost which i would normally
say there's not enough buckles i could
always say give me more buckle but that
is looks like it reached the buckle
limit you want to talk about a ledge
not a legit a legend a legend how many
how many looks does he have where you
could wear an outfit and you're like oh
he's michael jackson i mean michael
jackson like dozens of looks were you
like oh that's michael jackson he he
makes clothes things yeah i get back oh
i'm wearing michael jackson today like i
guess it was some music video he must
have worn a lawrence taylor
jersey who else has that many outfits
that you can recognize them from think
about that my daughters
my daughters have they have so many
freaking outfits i um you have you ever
seen the guy who looks just like what
did they just say rose mcgowan looks
like michael jackson
oh
there there's a guy there's a guy who
looks exactly like michael jackson and
it's pretty scary really never seen this
guy pimp you ever seen this guy google
mike that's at him right there michael
jackson look like you cannot tell them
apart
let me ask you this did he try to make
his face look like mike because i've
seen that people get surgeries to look
like him especially in person well yeah
i mean he definitely had some surgeries
but it's all natural
what
no prosthetics and no foundation wow
this guy from twitter looks exactly like
michael jackson it's all natural he's
got no fakes
wow he's got the same nose and michael
jackson i think did a lot to his nose
did do a lot to his nose so this gu
maybe this guy was supposed to be
michael jackson your butt is mine your
butt is mine
and the whole gang right there should
have been
whoa what's going on here we didn't sign
up for this
i'm asking for a friend beat your ass
not your butt is mine i'm asking for a
friend how do you go to jail for tax
evasion
what do you have to do
okay with taxes that you actually wind
up in prison i ask it for a friend i got
to i got the quickest summary for you go
ahead on how to do it okay what do you
do to taxes yeah to go to to go to jail
for taxes like like you definitely
definitely without a doubt you evade
them you evade them yeah
i guess you don't pay taxes but my
question is this let's say yeah again
ask for a friend argument say argument's
sake argument's like argument said
totally you're working in a field where
you get your money up front you don't
like like like like like a prairie
yeah like a plateau absolutely plateau
like i'm a marvel field you said yeah
you're working in fields like a field
your field
so let's say argument's sake you all
just throwing a number out there 138 138
967 15 cents in taxes yeah arbitrary
yeah you don't have that money in your
account because you just bought a house
um arbitrary yeah on saturn island yeah
just say just to make it
close yeah to the podcast yeah
hypothetic hypothetically at what point
does the irs say there's a payment plan
and at what point
i don't know if you're going to be going
to jail
you meaning the royals my friend who i'm
talking about in this in this equation
you go to jail immediate idiotly i think
that you will probably be uh
audited not you
not me the person who just bought a
house on south island knows they'll be
audited and then i think that like
first you have to be audited if you're
getting older that's not good okay but
then i think you probably will might be
fined maybe and then you got to pay it
back god and i and i'm imagining that
i don't know if it's a reasonable plan
plan payment plan or they'll just dock
your what do they what's that call when
they um going to shoulder
wages yeah but but but my question is
going to anytime you say garnish your
wages i always get hungry
yeah garnish your wages doesn't sound as
bad as what it means it's like oh yeah
i'm in a lime yeah exactly what i mean
like oh you're gonna put some extra
stuff with my wages yeah i'm like let's
get a martini yeah yeah garnish my way
just do whatever you want what's your
pay and that around it is just a mixed
green salad that's what it is just to go
it's a turn up
but then how do you go to bed sign up
for it if i didn't know what it meant on
paper i would check the box please
i would like a nice uh like a vegetable
medley yeah yeah yeah what am i one of
my options
how about this should you read this
superman's gay
what do you mean superman's fbg
full-blown gay
dc has confirmed that john kent earth's
new superman not clark anymore now we
got john kent the son of clark kent to
lois lane is a bisexual as the advance
art of superman son of cal number five
sees him share a kiss with new love
interest jay nakamura so so
superman's son is gay and he's into
japanese men
wow that's what it is
i don't know oh my god oh sorry i'm sure
she hasn't watched it in like 30 40
years i said watch it but if you want to
i said watch did you say watch or watch
oh you're saying she hasn't realized
she's aware of it
master kane tanaka listens religiously
she's she probably is listening and we
know at this point it'd have to have
gone to right now yeah yeah oh yeah it
definitely reached keynes yes
in the mountains of japan
um yeah so who is that what is this
guy's name ron kent
uh john johnson clark and lois's
bisexual son but
oh
son superman's son was going to be the
only one someone else came from
where is he from gibraltar
where's he from
and was given the name cal l at birth
got it
his name is cal dash l at birth so
actually superman is muslim which is
interesting
oh yeah well they're aliens
right you know they're from muslims are
aliens what are you saying
no superman
came here illegally didn't he he did
come here illegally see and that's the
thing
look what we could have lost if there
was strict rules he would have lost the
best illegal alien of all time superman
let me ask you a question superman comes
today
does he have to show his max card
he's not he's not above that he's not
about that he's not above that because
he's he's he's just susceptible cover 19
being from krypton as anybody else yeah
a nice suit but welcome to the delta
variant yeah yeah you know what superman
you could you don't have a vax do me a
favor one you sit in the ramada for 72
hours and then you can go save people
exactly because i'm not going to be out
here unless you go around the earth
really fast and bring us back to before
yeah the outbreak and then you get over
there and you figure something out by
the way speaking of that i saw something
really funny walking by i wa i was down
doing the comedy cell at mcdougall
street right in front of um
mineta tavern which is like the classic
so you know it's like a pretty you know
large uh homeless population that's down
in that area now um so there was a guy i
i saw it like right on the wall of mana
tavern full pulled down his pants taking
a massive dump against the wall and some
guy
walking his dog just like you know like
a gay west village guy walking his dog
with an umbrella it wasn't raining i
swear to god i saw this whole thing
happen he goes oh put a mask on
i know you're gonna say that he used his
dog [ __ ]
to pick up the guy's [ __ ] i was gonna be
like there's still humanity left in this
no it was like queen of the queens goes
oh man
they just kept walking like that
just down the drives our world in one
sentence literally crapping off the side
of the building and he's yelling at him
to put a mask on bonnie
and i saw it i mean perfectly i wish my
camera was rolling wow
ron kent is like
he's a separate thought iran ken's like
your butt is mine
now now yeah but
what do you got so i love this so so so
i didn't know they had a kid i didn't
know superman could impregnate a a human
i don't know i to be to be honest with
you i don't know clark kendall was
saying we're out
there we didn't know they're they're out
here
yeah and now also that
kid is old now so they had a kid a long
time ago yeah
yeah i guess i'm not up on my but the
but the person in this picture looks
like a white woman with pink hair she
looks like like she's uh antifa
but i guess it's a guy i guess that is a
boy
oh that's so cool is the dc thing in
rainbow that's cool that's cool
dc pro so um wow so so
so wow so
he's bi so he's so that that stands to
reason that we're going to see him go
through different relationships and
breakups of both sexes yeah he's going
to break this pink uh haired guy's heart
probably no i know many bisexual women
but i only know one bisexual man
uh i know many bisexual women yeah but i
only know what so i think a bisexual man
is a lot rare the only bisexual man we
both know is ian find that yeah he's
very old
that's the only bisexual man i've ever
met in my life yeah but he's fully
bisexual he has a girlfriend i know a
couple more but
i don't want to like say anything well
it's it's their choice i don't know if
the clause or not so i'm not going to
say whatever yeah
but no no it's like
three or two to like a million i know i
mean i i i would you know almost every
woman i've met have said they've had one
bisexual experience but very few men
have had a bisexual experience yeah yeah
yeah but it's going to happen more and
more now yeah then there's pan section
you know about peter pansexual is that
when you are attracted to not inanimate
objects no you're attracted to literally
everything everything at all peter
pansexual is literally
everything that anything that's moving
that's not a kid
right right i thought it could even be
like this couch and stuff right i think
it could be no no i'm not joking because
maybe i'm wrong but we wrote a pilot a
few years back that we pitched around
and we so thought i was getting picked
up and it didn't um
of the four of the guys from the show is
it like single camera scripted is that
my phone i apologize if it is no that
was freaking my phone oh okay
um i just have to keep i'm keeping my
phone on ring because my daughter the
nurse called the nurse called um and
said that my daughter has this tummy
ache and my the nurse from my daughter's
school is irish so she is just such a
nice lady she go hello
[Laughter]
i don't know if she has allergies
[Laughter]
you may want to come pick up this little
potato soon we'll see hold on
hi good
morning here
um the teacher called me over she said
delilah was complaining
she sounds like becky lynch
my stomach hurt her a little bit and i
said i said what you got to do is give
her some sort of right yeah i feel like
every single like i feel like that
message no disrespect but i feel like
that message right at the end will be
like and don't touch my lucky charm
like i feel like they always got to
throw it in yeah like she called she
called and she called at 11 and she goes
top of the morning to you
almost half of the afternoon
your daughter ate a lot of purple
horseshoes today
oh object sexuality or objectophilia is
a form of sexual or romantic attraction
focus on particular inanimate objects
individuals with disattraction may have
strong things of love and commitment to
certain items or structures of their
fixation so these are the people that
will have sex with the shield so that's
not pansexuality then so in this script
that we pitched murray was pansexual got
it and i remember writing jokes about it
but i thought that meant that he was
attracted to like anything but maybe i'm
misremembering yeah google pansexual
because i'd be calling peter pansexual
to be facetious
yeah pansexual because i said that once
at it it's not limited
has to do with regard to biological sex
gender or gender identity meaning okay
so not limited sexual choice but bio
what does not
scroll up a second what does that mean
not limited in sexual choice with regard
to biological sex oh that just means
gen i guess you'll have sex with males
females anybody that identifies as male
female transgender oh so that's all that
is i think that's what it
but is that just like no that can't be
that just means you're i think they're
saying if you're if you're a legal age
person if you're a person over 18
you you will get you will you will get
you if by pansexual
that's what they're saying uh so maybe
he wasn't pansexual in the in the script
then because we were writing jokes about
he was attracted to like a cabinet and
stuff like that so then he's more
objective maybe that was it yeah maybe
that's interesting
yeah i remember one time i remember one
time i was doing a college gig
um in uh i forgot where i was and there
was a
uh uh you know 18 19 year old you know
kid in the front row who was like
obviously gay like like no like but
wanted you to like very open like lamp
like loving it like he was like you know
like i would do a joke and he's like you
know what i mean baby like like clearly
gay you know
well i act like that though and i'm not
gay
so then i remember i remember i remember
the
you know me going you know doing jokes
or whatever and then at the end at the
end of college shows i always do a
question and answer because i think
that's what college kids are used to so
i'll do about 45 minutes to stand up and
then 15 minutes a question answer let
them ask me anything whatev whatever it
is even if it's about life whatever just
so i asked you know something with this
kid and i was like oh you know like i
made some joke like you know referring
to him like being gay and he was like
i'm actually not gay i'm beyond gay i'm
pansexual that's the first time i've
heard it i was like oh a peter pansexual
big laugh ha ha whatever he would love
you know he was he was like thank you so
much you made me feel so comfortable
that night somebody or you know like the
college newspaper wrote an article
saying that i was a homophobe saying
that i made the whole crowd feel
uncomfortable and cited this one thing
about me with the you know pansexual kid
and i was just like
what were you at the same show i was i
was like literally this kid messaged me
privately which i did not screenshot
because i don't want to expose him and
was like you made me feel so comfortable
thank you for being you you make me feel
like being you and blah blah blah you
know you make me feel like i can be me
blah blah blah and then someone else
took it on their behalf to call the
entire
how it went down and then only people
are going to read that are going to read
what that means other college kids yeah
meanwhile so funny because everyone in
the room who you affected positively
goes away with the real experience and
then potentially exponentially more
people get to read the fake experience
yeah it was so annoying where i was just
like what you know like what the hell
what the hell is this yeah but you know
whatever they were offended on that
person
yeah yeah so i gave the kid a [ __ ]
and said i was sorry yeah i mean what
more are you gonna do you know what can
you do yeah that's what i did because i
felt bad you know i think you think they
made him bisexual because they felt like
at large
people weren't ready for him to just be
outright gay i think
that's the case i think they should have
went balls to the wall opposite
direction
like ron kent is a pansexual yeah that
would have so i mean i would i i would
have bought a comic and i haven't bought
a comic since 91 how about this how
about this because we've been talking
about from from we started the podcast
we've been talking about a character
named john kent who's bisexual but you
keep saying ron canto so why don't we
make ron kent pansexual why don't we
have john kent's bisexual and half
brother let's pitch
as pansexual superman's other kid who's
a parent yeah i just feel like i just
see like
who's who's the superman villain i guess
the max luther i was gonna say uh the
wrong person but the riddler no that's
not the could be
yeah the ripler is by the way the
closest to being a gay superhero yeah a
gay villain when jim carrey played the
riddler i mean i was gonna say doom
who's that
i think it's all bad that's not a
spider-man spider-man
so who's the main batman villain
scarecrow
no no no the joker
joker's amazing but two faces about man
villain yeah but i just i just feel like
two faces bisexual long way for a bad
joke i just feel like people be like you
know
like there's a villain and he's he's
jailed and he got caught he's talking
about a prisoner he's like ron kent
[ __ ] me and the guy's like i know i
heard he's pansexual
it's a bad joke it's a real bad why not
no it's not he screwed me meaning i he
caught me and i'm in jail now but since
he's pansexual there's a lot of
misunderstandings going on in dc
universe exactly yeah exactly i feel
like
could you imagine somebody's like my mom
comes out as pansexual like somebody you
would never expect what would you do if
your dad pulled a caitlyn jenner
if i say
it's bad but i just mean like if your
dad came and like he did to his family
and just said hey i've been living like
wow this life that i don't know wow
and that late late stages like you're
that that would be your dad now because
i think caleb has late stage caitlyn
jenner no
i think kayla jenner now is in our 70s
right so how when did she um transit
transition five years ago 10 years ago
so like around like i don't know how to
do that at 75. so okay so if he
transitions now
it would it would
obviously whatever your dad needs and
wants but like
it would it would i'm trying to put
myself in the position of their family
and how that was
to have their dad
in his 70s transition but here's the
thing is
you didn't come out of nowhere like they
had to know privately that caitlyn
jenner had to at some point come out
with
the girl's clothes on
no i think they used to say that i think
on kardashians i i remember seeing a
clip where they maybe i saw her commit i
don't know who i thought that he would
uh dress
in front of clothing if my dad came out
if my dad came out as caitlyn jenner
right now
your dad came out as caitlyn jenner yeah
my father caitlyn jenner i've been
feeling that i was caitlin jenner my
whole life and
i think you know what at this point i
think it'd actually be fine i think it'd
actually be it'd be fun it'd be fun it'd
be one of those things where it's like
wow i have like
i have like a new dad for the you know
whatever remaining time he has left i
have like this new interesting dad right
who's just now you know
now i know when he calls me it's you
know he's going to have a story right
you know
hey how are the kids like now it's gonna
be like you never believe what my day
was because i've been i'm go i'm going
to my senior citizen years
borderline having dementia with a full
[ __ ] so that would be
so i would be like wow dad now i i
actually want to hear you're not just
going to call me and talk to me about
the yankees your dad your dad exactly
how he is right now like his
tony tampa tony tony
you put heels on him and you as a city
block long yeah how far does he get
before he breaks both ankles i would say
i would say
my dad can't pull that off it takes
skill i mean there's a video of him
there's no skill but
was in heels on the show one time in new
orleans walking up and down bourbon
street yeah and uh i almost broke my
ankle like four times in like 20 minutes
well you know his son if it's any his
son
and i send you this video i literally
take four steps in my driveway and fall
down on the floor
ankle i just throw it on the pod yeah i
don't know yeah throw can we put on go
to my instagram
put in my pod this is me
literally walking five steps in very
comfortable shoes i will say though this
was a day after i did yoga for the first
time so there is something about my
ankles being too flexible
i think or maybe so weak that i think
yoga made me fall look at this this is
just me taking three
oh my god you hit the pavement i know
and then look i'm just
i'm just start talking to myself but
don't you pick up something you tripped
over and say it out loud yeah
oh that's why it was a piece of my
daughter's bike
no yeah
my
are you talking to yourself right now
for real are you knowing that this audio
and you're gonna be laughing at this so
no the who i'm actually talking to or is
there someone to watch you my neighbor
was across the street sitting on her
stoop and she saw the entire
thing
and then she had to walk to the bus stop
to pick up our kids like it didn't
happen she was like are you okay i was
like yeah i was like i was like just my
wrist starts and then she didn't talk
about it for like the rest of the day
but then she went to go get her nails
done with jasmine and that's all they
talked about they watched this video
like a hundred times no and she was
saying she was like i was gonna piss
myself with laughter but i genuinely
thought he got hurt yeah it wasn't a
graceful fall no you hit the pavement
there i bounce so so if i'm gonna take
five steps in my driveway and that's
gonna happen i would argue that on the
very first step of my father in high
heels he would blow both his knees out
right i think he'd blow both of them
i will say though i will say though my
dad you know we're going to well this
comes out next thursday right not this
thursday
weeks from now oh yeah because my dad is
coming you know i have shows in
nashville and my dad's coming with us
to nashville and we plan to get him in
cowboy boots and a cowboy hat maybe we
try to see how far he can walk in cowboy
boots and we film that and we'll put
that on at the end of a hay back boots
are not easy they're not easy they're
hard to get on and off too how about
this my parents my my father my
stepmother always my stepmother's dream
has been to go to nashville dream all
chamber would do is go to nashville
she's like oh we can finally go to
nashville we can drive because now we
live in florida and it's the south do
you know it takes 15 hours for them to
get to nashville on car from they're
driving from florida for 15 hours when
i'm like
it's the same time from new york right
just fly but they will not fly it's like
a 90-minute flight or some [ __ ] yeah
then my dad calls and he goes out he
goes yeah he goes oh we got to call aaa
because we got to um we got to get the
directions
they give us the best route i was like
yeah just use waves he goes no we go to
triple a we get the directions they
print it out they map it out they tell
us what hotel to stay at and i said they
charge you for that he was like yeah but
how else am i going to get there
oh my goodness he's like dad just use
the gps please triple a is still going
strong for people like that
when i was little i mean like in the
like 80s like early 80s my mom used to
have that gold like when you get triple
a it's like this silver foil sticker
with the triple a and you put on the
bumper sticker yeah yeah you put it on
the bumper so like they know yeah like
when they pull up that your triple a
my my um
okay let's see automotive double a mco
let's see
i'm going to take a stab at what triple
a stands for american automotive
allegiance wow that's a that was a very
off the dome guess yeah that i think
could be accurate america american
automobile association wow wow
allegiance why would you stay allegiance
even i'll even give you automotive for
automobile you get two out of three i
said american automotive yeah but i'll
give that to you yeah the same word it's
the same root word american automobile
association wow wow the
aaa which yeah that's run out of
business tom tom gps map quest remember
map quests dude you would print out the
directions what a dangerous thing that
was that was driving trying to read
pieces of paper and if you know how many
times page eight was page seven yes and
i made a wrong turn now i'm in a ravine
because i've
my car ended up in a ball pit at a
mcdonald's playhouse yeah that's what it
is
i used to print him out then he used to
take like 10 minutes to print it out
because it was the old like dot matrix
princess yeah and then you'd like i used
to staple them so i didn't get page
confusion right but i would also mark it
up with my own notes and make big things
so i wouldn't like i have to look at the
but yeah you need them when you're when
you're on a trip then you're on page
seven
like and you and you don't know where
you are and you're like trying to be
like in point three turn off the and you
used to get like swerve off the road all
the time it matters because now because
it's like and you didn't get a ticket
for that there was no ticket then now
you gotta take it if you're texting and
driving but i feel like map question
driving is even worse and more dangerous
because you're stressed out you're
looking for turns yeah it's like if i
want to text a little bit yeah if i want
to text my booty out right that's fine
it's a quick second yeah i'm texting you
so what they're saying to us now is
print out our directions right and lay
them on the dash yeah and then figure it
out as you're going in real time yes if
you don't map questions okay if you had
a passenger yes if you didn't have a
passenger i swear to god it was like a
60 chance you may crash yeah yeah and
then forget about it and then you better
and you better hope the passenger with
map quest wasn't an objective feeling or
pansexual next you know they're banging
the directions thing in the paper the
background all the pages are stuck
together now because they they got horny
yeah it must be tough hanging out with
an object the feelingist yeah because
then it's because you're like don't
don't [ __ ] it yeah
just don't [ __ ] that don't [ __ ] that
yeah you're like no yeah just have lunch
don't [ __ ] that
come on yeah let's get out of here don't
[ __ ] the car yeah what are you doing
everything he's got his murmur's got his
penis in the muffler again
now we can't drive do you remember
before mapquest where you got on the
phone it was nothing with foreign and
they were like go three lights i think
wow you probably will pass you're gonna
pass like a a pep boys i don't really
remember that there's a hard left and a
yeah and then you used to write the
directions out by hand by their memory
it's like oh you go about i want to call
it
two three miles
you you
what was that three one one no you call
your friend no the person that you're
going to gives you the direction oh i
thought that was just service i don't
remember that i thought it was a service
where like a guy from that town just
picks up
the directions
when you just when you had dictated
directions from the person you had to
go visit my pool guy the guy that does
my pool
was asking me for directions to get to
my house i was like just gps it but he's
so old-school he also writes i don't
know what
business plan this is people are still
giving bills and then having me send
checks in for the bills it's like can
you just get a venmo or have have a
credit card swipe get anything yeah but
i have to now send in a check i got to
go into my dresser drawer get a
checkbook fill it out then fill out the
ledger
then get postage then lick a stamp right
it takes so and then i gotta go down to
the
to the to the to the to the mailbox i
don't want to fill out a heath ledger
you know what i mean i just want to give
you my chevy chase credit card you
balance no no i know new balance yeah
yeah no no i can't because i still
balance when i write a check i don't
even know how to balance your checkbook
i gotta be honest with you some credits
but what does that mean balance of
checkbook so let's say i have a thousand
dollars i write you check for 300. yeah
i know and now i have 700 left but what
is it what do i have to balance what do
i have to do now in the checkbook to
balance it well that's a pretty round
number that's easy to remember but if
you got bills coming in and out all
month long and you got direct deposits
and you're paying 20 different things
and you can't keep track of your balance
but but on my on my app it tells me how
much money i have in my account and how
much was taken out well yeah now with
the apps you really don't need it so
that's what i'm saying so the balance of
the checkbook thing was really to make
sure you have enough money in your
account yeah
yeah sally babes did you know that more
than half of americans so like millions
and millions of people are on a high
deductible health insurance plan and
they're on the hook for thousands of
dollars of deductibles co-pays and
sky-high premiums sure for many people
in the u.s concerned about the cost of
health insurance there aren't any good
options there aren't either go uninsured
or you pay through the notes for high
deductible with questionable coverage
yeah you don't know what kind of
coverage you're getting all the time all
because of uh broken health insurance no
and you know what it's like it's kind of
like being stuck with an outdated cable
tv plan you don't even know about
netflix that's right that's what it's
like well i don't know
how netflix is the netflix health
insurance that's what it is it's a
better way to pay it isn't health
insurance it's
health insurance you better shut your
money better way to pay your medical
expenses the better way to pay your
medical expenses it is not health
insurance at all
it is a community of people who are
tired of paying for the broken system a
place where you can get simple flexible
and affordable way to pay your health
care being in the crowd health community
can save you hundreds of dollars monthly
and put thousands of dollars back in
your pocket do you want to save hundred
dollars monthly and put thousands of
dollars back in your pocket then you got
to go to crowdhealth so you just press a
button to receive virtual care anytime
anywhere you use their app you find
nearly any doctor in the country rank
from one start to five star you scan
bills you throw them away crowd health
takes it from there and you guys my
friends are going to get a sweet deal
crowd health is able to offer amazing
prices because of its community of
health conscious members so all you have
to do what do they have to do for a
limited time our listeners get their
first month free and if you've been a
member crowd health will include a
fitness wearable which i think that is
like uh you're wearing fitness artists
like maybe like maybe like a a step is
that like a step monitor like a step
whatever it is wearable dude i'm signing
up just to get the fitness wearable i
love fitness wearable that's 30 days to
try risk-free uh plus the fitness
wearable go to joincrowdhealth.com
fit and enter our code hey babe at sign
up that's join crowdhealth.com fit promo
code hey babe crowdhealth is not health
insurance it is a community powered
alternative terms and conditions may
apply they love us i mean how much we
love them and they love us seriously
dwight hello i don't i don't know of
another company that is that has been
with us more than hello friends is
telling fresh even paying us anymore i
don't know i don't freaking i think i
work there i seriously do i have a shift
in hella fresh tonight i swear to god i
can't stop making yellow fresh food
i love it so much i love when it comes i
get all excited dude i i told you i've
been saying this week after week i
legitimately know how to cook now yeah i
know how to cook and i eat and i
freaking i love throwing spices in there
there are 50 menu and market items to
choose from every week including
vegetarian calorie smart gourmet options
there's plenty of variety what i like
about them is their food is culturally
diverse it is and they have cool recipes
for the fall like meatloaf la mom or one
pot broccoli mac and cheese pumpkin
cinnamon rolls
pumpkin cinnamon rolls
blow your balls off absolutely all you
got to do
you're gonna get 14 free meals right now
just go to hellofresh.com slash hey babe
14 and use the code heybabe14 for up to
14 free mails including the free
shipping that's hellofresh.com heybabe14
and use the code hey babe 1-4 for up to
14 free meals including free shipping
hello fresh america's number one meal
kit
yeah yeah so that's to know what you
have
not only that you have enough money but
yeah because people would not know if
they had enough to to clear a check you
know right but now you do control on the
app in the app yeah yeah and when you
write a check it should be showing up in
the app as well if your bank is worth
its salt
by the way i forgot to tell you this i
went to i went pumpkin picking with
delilah and my whole family and violet
everybody my whole family we went to tom
thurns or thurnvon park something it was
great in new jersey okay i had spicy
donuts i had pumpkin pie i eat it full
so i'm ready for pumpkin what i'm about
to tell you i ate an entire pumpkin pie
with my hands in the car driving home in
traffic was it a personal pumpkin pie or
a regular full-time a full family size
pumpkin pie eight with my hands let you
do that she let you eat a whole pumpkin
because i got mad at her she was like
chris you need to stop i was like don't
tell me what to do you're in the past
because she you're holding the map quest
directions i was like and i ate the pie
and then she was one of those things
like because i got like a little caddy
with her because talking she's like you
know what do whatever the [ __ ] you want
like that you know and then just and
then just sat looking this way for the
whole time yeah and and then i ate the
entire pie to spite her
and even but my daughter was like when i
got in the car my daughter was like she
hits me in the stomach she goes you're
on a diet that's right my little
six-year-old she got you girl and i died
and then today just this morning i tried
to i tried to have a pudding for
breakfast she goes yeah i didn't die
i was like oh my god this little rat
butt
so they had a thing where you could
shoot pumpkins like take that gun and
you know what i'm talking about what
pumpkin sling it's called you can go
dude you could sling pumpkin and corn
you could take a bb gun you could kill
somebody well no you shoot it to the
open field but you could shoot pump uh
corn kernels out like that like with a
little bb gun no facing a field and then
you could take a thing uh a catapult a
catapult like a slingshot and sling
pumpkins bro i saw this ten-year-old kid
who was fat i mean like
like a 300 pound 10 year old but a
strong kid pull this like a mini big pun
like a mini big pun pull this slingshot
back and let this pumpkin fly and it hit
a worker in the back no dude i watched
this pumpkin explode all over this guy's
back and him fall right into the field
and then get up and he just yeah you
know he was the warrior should have
nothing to say that's the pumpkin
landing zone yeah well no but but
because it was little kids nobody
thought that a pumpkin was going to go
this far i mean this kid launched he
used all of his weight yeah and then he
i mean he yelled something in spanish
what do you guys think a pumpkin is like
uh
a gourd
is it fruit or vegetable you're saying
that yeah what do you guys think
i think it's
i think it's uh
it grows
right is it
a tree it's a pumpkin a tree no no we
went we went pumpkin picking together
last year no i know but i thought about
the grounds no i understand but i don't
know if they're taking them off the
trees to place them in the field or
they're growing up out of the ground
where they stand oh wait a minute
when we walked around all those pumpkins
they were already loose
the apples were oh wait but there was
there was a pumpkin field in the apple
field right did we see pumpkins last
year we thought we did apples i did
apples with you but i also did pumpkins
no they had pumpkins too well i barely
saw you because i got lost in the maze
yes yeah i was lost in the corn maze for
about it was like yeah there was like a
like a like like a like the shining maze
it was crazy they had one made they had
a maze in tom tom van thorns
tom thumbs park in monmouth they had a
maze that said you had a kid's one it
was 15 minutes adults won two and a half
hours it said wow so that's how crazy
they get with the maze oh i would never
do that never like what if you've had
enough at 40 minutes yeah and then you
just lost in there yeah
i know
maybe one two and a half hours i could
watch dances with wolves what are we
doing for halloween babe we're gonna do
the thing you said yes we're gonna do it
yeah but what about the costumes we're
gonna
there will be an email going around i'm
on the email list a text there will be
text going around and i'm on it yeah i i
will put you okay
okay
my mom's in it's a hundred percent it's
on halloween that's what i'm saying yeah
and also chris we had a fight derosa to
agree to go last hey babe joe derosa
wouldn't you i know jojo rosa filled in
for me for the for the for the last 10
minutes of hey babe how did you guys
feel that worked
it flowed good yeah i i'm trying to
think about if our dynamic our dynamic
in a hey babe was any closer to our
dynamic well yeah i want to do a tape
i'm going to come in for the last 10
minutes if it taste buds
that's the only way that this works
pumpkins are actually a fruit just like
batman's son many people
sorry
you're not talking about you're not
talking about ron kent you just said
batman's son yes exactly and son is a
gourd it's a gory you're being literal
yes i wasn't talking about superman
yeah no i'm not talking about rock yeah
talk about batman so take that and
because because batman's son yeah is
like you said he actually gives birth to
strawberries yeah yeah yeah yeah
he's a squash with bad ears he's a
squashy batteries pumpkins are actually
a fruit many people think it should be
our national fruit that's a good point
in other countries in halloween first of
all do they have halloween in other
countries second of all
is are they pumpkin crazy they have
halloween but are they pumpkin obsessed
like the americans are we are pumpkin
obsessed yeah pumpkin ever what about on
canada box day what do they do crazy
with pumpkins on canada boxster was it
canadian new year's just this week is it
canadian new year's yeah
i thought it was chinese christmas it
was getting it might be both it was
canadian new year which i didn't really
understand did they just do they go by a
different it's just do they traditional
they go by do they go buy the pagan
calendar and we go by the by the julian
yeah we go by the way we're going to go
roman i look like
this gregor roman stop you go greco
rolls gekko roams no how do they
celebrate new year's encounter they say
many people start on january 1st they do
it december
i swear to god you were just in toronto
i swear to god i was at um
i was at a uh
at a restaurant the other night and
people were like oh we're all here
selling celebrating canada canadian new
year's
maybe it's really canadian maybe it's
because it's like the beginning of
hockey season is it canada day maybe it
was canada day canada day and isn't
there box day what's canada box day
unclear you know i'm talking isn't there
a canada box day or is it
canada box day
what is box day in canada oh boxing day
canada box day sounds perverted it's
kind of the box there's a whole nother
bag of worms yeah canada box days that's
the point i watch
wait no so i don't know but i'm telling
you there was a room full of 30 people
celebrating canadian new year well
or so they told me since you're now the
international manager someone bacon buys
there was someone baking pies and we go
oh what's the pies for he goes everyone
in the back is celebrating canadian pie
cherry i didn't see it
well i'm saying was it was it was it uh
savory or sweet i didn't see the pie it
was a pie making station derosa saw it
and came and told me and then we asked
what's the
derosa went to toronto with you no no i
wasn't in toronto this was in red hook
brooklyn oh yeah i was at a restaurant
and it was
coincidentally i was in toronto two days
prior i understand your confusion where
were we out in red hook
uh i went to red hook tavern that's a
great place right hooked up i went to
red hook town for the best cheeseburger
ever but while we were waiting to be
called for our table we walked over to
sunny's bar god it's somebody's bar and
red hook is like an old
like divey like thing and it's been
there for 100 years yeah it's the best
yeah it's great do you think it's the
best burger in brooklyn red hook taverns
burger i think red hook taverns burger
and i'll go on record and i i'm happy to
to be to find another one as good as
this i think it's the best burger i've
ever had what yes what makes it so good
potato roll
it's a sesame
crispy brioche roll i think very tough
very tough
sesame brioche is not for everybody and
it toasted perfectly where like the
edges are really crisp but the center is
like still or whatever the patties like
this thick it's dry aged beef they put a
really big helping of cheese on top and
then underneath it in a full disc form
they put a grilled onion the entire size
of the bun and the patty so they so
every bite you bite into is an onion
you're getting a grilled onion in there
as well
water is then they served three potato
wedges
golden brown with some sea salt on it
and the most delicious crisp perfect
uh pickle that you've ever had in your
entire life it's just perfect it almost
is hard to finish every time you finish
i'm like i got to come back in three
months right because you're so heavy
it's so heavy yeah i have a question to
go back to the people that's it right by
the way you know what i like about pimp
today the little the lacroix he's
drinking matches his outfit
yeah he's got like a pizza pit's got a
purple shirt and like you see foam pants
and then the lacroix candy's drinking
which is the
pampa what's the flavor pimple lemonade
pamplona virus pamplona virus that's the
hpv lacroix the pamplona it's just i've
never seen a lacroix pimp loose i've
never seen somebody match their decor to
their cannabis it is wild you look like
you you look like you literally you
you you look like you're from miami like
like you look like you just fell off a
wall in a hotel room in miami you were
an art installation like a thai lacroix
boy
all right oh spaghettio
getting a little bald back there oh look
at me i need to keep what i got i got
this one thing right here for always i
want to keep it right where it is and
that's where it keeps comes in that's
where it keeps comes in i noticed i was
fading i was getting a little
loosey-goosey in the back and then boom
i slapped the little keeps on there and
now i'm my hair's growing i got more
pubic hair than ever
let's talk about this two out of three
men will experience some form of hair
loss by the time they're 35. more than
50 ml men in the u.s suffer from male
pattern baldness this is a thing that
affects everybody and they're only two
fda approved medications that can
prevent hair loss keeps offers both it's
a simple stress-free way to keep your
hair everybody wants to keep their hair
so you keep your hair with with keeps
it's a low cost treatment start at ten
dollars a month and keeps offering the
generic versions discreet packaging so
nobody knows you're a little bald baby
and nobody has any idea it has more five
star reviews than any of its competitors
prevention is key treatments can take
four to six months see results so act
fast if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss and i'm according to
these stats most of our listeners are go
to keps.com
hey babe to receive your first month of
treatment absolutely free that's
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash hey babe to get
your first month free k-e-e-p-s dot com
slash
hey all right i wanna talk to you about
live streaming please okay let me talk
to you about it yeah a lot of people are
waiting all afternoon what is live
stream well what live stream is is if
you want to be smart and pay off your
credit card balances with a credit card
consolidation loan from light stream
that's good you do it up rates start at
4.98
apr with auto pay and excellent credit
so yeah the rate's fixed it'll never go
up over life alone there's no change in
rates you can get a loan from five
thousand to a hundred thousand there's
no fees because you know what livestream
believes they believe that people with
good credit deserve a better loan
experience and that's exactly what they
deliver which i like them i appreciate
that because a lot of people it's very
easy for some of these other companies
to say you know what you don't have good
credit you're not a good person and then
they slap you around they throw you away
they just
they rough you up they rough you up what
is your credit score under six hundred
and then what do you want right you
wanna spruce up one of your half baths
not like you know you wanna what do you
wanna do you wanna go on a family
vacation yeah something like that they
know good people have bad credit and bad
people have good credit it's what it is
we're human beings just for our
listeners apply now and get a special
interest rate discount and save even
more the only way to get the discount
that we're talking about is to go to
lightstream.com
hey babe that's l-i-g-h-t-s-t-r-e-a-m
dot com slash hey babe
apr and include 0.50
auto pay discount lowest rates requires
excellent credit terms and conditions
apply and officers are subject to change
without notice visit livestream.com for
more information nice that's the part of
the commercial like when it's on tv that
the guy is a speed reader yeah yeah we
didn't we couldn't do it no but i
thought you did good okay thank you
tyler
your shirt is tie-dye i think it is and
your pants are not but your pants are
uh floral
and uh what do i what am i seeing there
what are those it's like a seafoam it's
it's unbelievable
yeah and
it goes
and then your glasses match them both
you know what pimp does better than
anyone you're dressed like a pimp he's a
he is a pimp he's become he's he looks
homeless and as a pimp at the same time
it was inadvertent wasn't that your
gamer name yeah you grew into your name
you look like a homeless pimp you do
look like you're homeless and a pimp
it's a coin flip for if if you see this
guy in the street it's a coin flip is he
a pimp or is he homeless or is he both
or is he bombing he's introducing both
he's the first ever
homeless pimp maybe not
i don't know no did you realize you were
fulfilling your own prophecy i did once
i realized i'm gonna live on the road
right and i'm never gonna be home right
and then but what about with your with
your fashion sense i've just always
loved bright colors so yeah no it looks
fantastic because what pimp does is is
even before you came in here he got a
new shirt he got a new um oh it's over
there somewhere a red polo button down
which is awesome and he puts that with
the purple and all that and it doesn't
affect uh you know somebody would say
there's no way i can wear that these
colors don't match nothing matches but
when he puts it on it all flows because
he he he doesn't care about fashion so
much that it's fashionable yeah yeah
without a doubt
no
most people can't pull it over and the
reason they can't pull it off is they
would let that outfit with them what
pimp does is pimp wears the outfit
that's what he does pimp comes first the
alpha comes second the alpha falls in
line you look at him and you believe it
i believe if you put that on i literally
probably would die i wouldn't i would
have done it on the spot i would have
like some type of stroke
a sudden stroke dude i wouldn't put and
then you would never be able to if i
paid you if i said if you walk down the
street
and out and i set up a hundred people
that you're going to pass they don't
know you and i'm i'm going to tell you
that after you pass this 100 people i'm
going to catch them on the other side
i'm going to give them a clipboard i'm
going to ask them a series of questions
right and i'm going to ask them the guy
that just passed you in that outfit do
you think that he was serious and
confident and that outfit suited him 100
out of 100 would say no because no
matter even for a million dollars no
matter what you did i would not believe
that you can get into a headspace where
you would believe that you belonged in
an outfit and you could pull it off and
you were wearing it like he does it's
not easy to do it's not easy to do not
easy to do i will say
most black people can do it yes and
that's a given everyone knows that i
mean just steve harvey to anyone yeah i
mean they can do like
and that's one of my biggest i envy the
black community for their ability to
literally wear whatever they want and
make it look good only babies justin
timberlake and black people can wear
fedoras and speaking of speaking of
speaking of it's
true i can pull it off yeah well justin
timberlake is yeah he's i don't even
think he is a race right justin
timberlake's just a human yeah he's just
if anything but speaking of gorgeous
speaking of gorgeous black men yeah
shout out tom brady oh my god shout out
tom brady
yeah did you know that he did that i i i
did know i did know he won it all yeah
he won uh and they were in tampa bay
which is the first time that happened
that's never happened i'd be remiss if i
didn't mention patrick mahomes and the
kansas city chiefs yeah they're doing
big yeah but yeah patrick mahomes is on
yeah they get another chance the chiefs
they don't look good this year though i
was asking
oh pimp was asking questions asking you
a question
because the canadian people
i because of impractical jokers do you
feel like most people you meet might be
pranking you
well
interesting questions no what i feel is
most people i meet think i'm doing it to
them got it so if they see me they
assume there's a high chance they're on
the show the issue is i film the show a
few hours a day and then the rest of
those hours of the day is just me
yeah i'm way more in my real life than
on the show but whenever anyone sees me
they assume so anytime i'm in public
anywhere they assume they're on the show
yeah so i always have to go through that
rigmarole where i'm like no you're like
am i on the show right now you're like
no you're at my wedding yeah yeah yeah
yeah but um because a few of the stories
you tell i feel like you don't know
you're being pranked like the cop who's
like oh this is your biggest fan we just
got in a car accident oh that happens to
me a lot yeah that's how they fly with
you once remember and the pilot you made
believe like there was something dude i
i literally
i forgot i don't know what airline this
was but whatever airline this was wow
suck it
we were late we were like not late but
we landed at like four o'clock ish and
had a show like seven so it's like you
want to get to the hotel i forgot all
about whatever well i get off i get off
the flight i'm waiting for sal like well
you know i'm we're all you know a couple
of rows difference and i'm waiting for
sal
everybody gets off the flight i'm like
what the hell is going on i'm like
texting him like are you okay like did i
miss you did you get off ahead of me and
whatever
10 minutes go by
sal comes off and he's just gone
and i'm like what the hell happened he
goes the pilot
they played a prank on me
the pilot and the flight attendants
played a prank on them and said that
there was some type of
uh vicious infectious infectious
chemical that was on his seat and he had
to
sign this paperwork or something what
was it oh
the flight attendant comes over to me
somewhere like an hour before the flight
ends whatever it was or a half hour she
hands me an official piece of paper that
is printed out and it says like it's
very technical it says like the seat
number it says a lot of coding and it's
like it's almost like one of those dot
matrix printers it looks very like
official like she tore it off and it was
like coming over the wire and she's like
uh the person it was identified after
post flight last flight that the person
in your seat was identified with an
infectious disease or something
something of that pre-cove something of
that nature like to which i read it and
i did not anticipate it being a joke
because it was such a serious thing you
were terrified and they said that you
please do not get up out of your seat
please do not like whatever and when the
plane lands please stay until the plane
has deported and so someone can come in
and tend to this with you and i was like
oh my god like what
like emma do i have a disease what is
this disease like i got to stay on and
then everyone got off i waited and then
the pilot comes over and he's like yeah
i'm the pound i was like yes and i'm
like so nervous and he goes
and i was like what are you talking
about he goes
i love the show
i was like wait what what i was like 300
pounds 300 people just gotta hold the
plane and this the left for the last 40
minutes i thought i had a disease
i mean it's just so stupid because i
remember one of the flight defense
coming up to be like hey is that sal
from practical jokers and i was like uh
i don't know and then they're like oh
but you came on the plane with him is
that the show i remember saying that i
was like i don't know and he goes and
they go but you came on the plane with
him i was like i was like yeah i'm not
sure they're like they're like do you
think it'd be fun to play a prank on him
and i swear to god i remember saying no
don't do that right don't do that i
remember saying that and they did it
anyway they did it just [ __ ] yeah
you know well i will tell you this
though after that he's like let me get a
picture i was like all right you know
let's do it
and then uh
he go i go man i go i don't i'm like i
can't believe you did that like i
thought i i really got scared of it i'm
like ah you gotta let me sit in the
cockpit now and he goes okay and i just
went up there and i sat in the cockpit
and they took and then they took my
phone and taking pictures of me in the
cockpit okay actually it's not that bad
yeah i was like man this is i feel like
we're we're breaking a lot of laws and
rules he broke he broke law after law
after law that guy shout out that guy
though shut off the guy it's actually
sully you've heard
do you you know what speaking of
speaking to the hudson i um durham north
carolina which is which is not far from
the hudson river that's right
yes dora is it
of course it is
what do we oh that was a goof yeah i
mean i didn't know if the hudson's i
know hudson ran somewhere i didn't know
i don't i don't pretend to know
everything
nor do i pretend to know waterways i
know what durham is close to the um
probably it's got to be close to the
blue ridge mountains it's north carolina
okay probably i don't know anything
about geography all right not much i
don't know much but i know i love you
durham home of the duke blue satans that
may be
all there is to know the duke blue
devils yes yes
yes i'm on that team when we were like
oh maybe i'm older than you but that
that whole grand hill christian
leightoner oh my god like dominant like
insane team who else was on that team
was cherokee parks on that team i don't
know yeah no not that not that year when
they played unlv they were like
larry johnson that was the augment that
was insane that was an insane series and
i'm not even college bowl that much
sunday december 26 will be in grand
prairie texas aka close to dallas monday
the 27th of december we are in san
antonio texas
the stars at night are big and bright
deep in the heart
continue with texas tuesday december
28th we will be in sugarland texas which
is near houston wednesday december 29th
st louis missouri thursday december 30th
in columbus ohio and new year's eve 2021
into 2022 join us friday december 31st
in cincinnati
coach k from duke oh okay that's how you
say his last name yes shazky
the one that begins with a k yeah mike
shashefsky how did you think your k name
starts with a sound that's how the
polish people oh wow i didn't know that
absolutely all right all right this has
been hey babe it's been hey babe
superman sons bisexual
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
babe hey babe hey